the Joe Rogan experience what was it
like when the dude threw the steel balls
at the window and they were supposed to
not break and it broke well yeah I mean
oh no you know that our demos are
authentic so I was not expecting that a
night and then I think I muttered under
my breath though know what you didn't
Steve Jobs it no III definitely swore
but you know I didn't think the Micra
pick it up but it did and it but it's so
like we practiced this you know buying
the scenes yeah it has a we don't do we
don't do like tons of practice for for
our demos because we work we're working
on the car it's like we you know we're
building new technologies and and and
proving the the fundamental product so
we were not spending it like they were
doing like hundreds of you know practice
things or anything like that we don't
have time for that but the the out just
hours before the demo both fronts
you know is a head of design and and I
were in the studio throwing steel balls
at the window or just bouncing right off
I'm like okay this seems pretty good
seems like we got it okay and then I we
think what happened was that when we
went when franz hit the the door with
the sledgehammer you know sure like like
this is this is like yeah yeah
exoskeleton
you know high-strength hardened steel
you can literally take wind up with a
sledge hammer
you know full-on double handed sledge
hammer and hit the door and there's not
even a dent it's cool but we think that
that cracked the corner of the glass at
the bottom and then once you crack the
corner of the glass the years game over
so then when you threw the bowl that
that's what cracked the glass that's
true it didn't shatter the whole thing
like a regular window would either which
would just dissolve right
so in hindsight the ball should have
been first sledgehammer set yeah yeah
you live you learn
yeah exactly
[Applause]